>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
AND WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A
FOX NEWS ALERT.
WOW, WHAT A DAY IN THE
WASHINGTON SEWER AND SWAMP ONCE
AGAIN WHILE YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY MAKE THIS A GREAT
COUNTRY, ARE FACING, YOU KNOW, A
DELUGE OF SERIOUS PROBLEMS, LIKE
RECORD INFLATION, RECORD HIGH
GAS PRICES, RECORD NUMBERS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, RECORD
HOMICIDES IN SO MANY OF OUR
TOWNS AND CITIES WHILE THE SWAMP
CREATURES ON CAPITOL HILL, THEY
WERE BUSY WITH YET ANOTHER
ANTI-TRUMP KANGAROO COURT AND
SHOW TRIAL WHERE THE OUTCOME, AS
WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU, HAS BEEN
AND REMAINS PREDETERMINED.
IT'S BEEN THAT WAY SINCE DAY
ONE.
INSTEAD OF HONEST HEARINGS ON
HOW TO PROTECT OUR INSTITUTIONS,
OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS, TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE, THE
CAPITAL.
INSTEAD OF EVER ALLOWING RIOTS
THAT THOSE THAT OCCURRED IN THE
SUMMER OF 2020 FROM EVER, EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN, WE SEE NOTHING
BUT BLIND, NEVER ENDING RAGE,
WHAT IS SEEMINGLY AN
OBSESSIVE-COMPULSIVE CULT LIKE
RAGE AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
IT NEVER ENDS.
CLEARLY TRUMP HATERS, FOR THEM,
JANUARY 6 THIS JUST ANOTHER
EXCUSE TO SMEAR DONALD TRUMP,
ANYONE WHO SUPPORTS HIM.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT SAFETY AND
SECURITY AND SECURING THE
CAPITAL OR GET INTO THE TRUTH.
THIS IS NEVER BEEN ABOUT HAVING
A FAIR AND SERIOUS HEARING AND
PROCEEDING SO WE CAN COME UP
WITH SOLUTIONS.
TODAY WE HEARD MORE RUMORS, A
TON OF HEARSAY, AND, WOW, A LOT
OF IMPEACHED TESTIMONY THAT WE
WILL GET TO IN A SECOND AND THIS
WHY HEARSAY IS NEVER ADMISSIBLE
IN A COURT OF LAW, INCLUDING
THIS WILD CLAIM NUMBER FORMER
LOW LEVEL WHITE HOUSE STAFFER.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID SOMETHING
TO THE EFFECT OF "I AM THE
ACTING PRESIDENT, TAKE ME UP TO
THE CAPITAL NOW."
TO WHICH BOBBY RESPONDED "SIR,
WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
WEST WING."
THE PRESIDENT REACHED UP TOWARDS
THE FRONT OF HIS VEHICLE TO GRAB
AT THE STEERING WHEEL.
MR. ENGEL GRABBED HIS ARM AND
SAID SIR, YOU NEED TO TAKE YOUR
HAND OFF THE STEERING WHEEL, WE
ARE GOING BACK TO THE WEST WING,
WE ARE NOT GOING TO THE CAPITAL.
MR. TRUMP THEN USED HIS FREE
HAND TO LUNGED TOWARDS BOBBY
ENGEL AND WHEN HE HAD RECOUNTED
THE STORY TO ME, HE MOTIONS
TOWARDS HIS CLAVICLE'S.
>> Sean: WHAT YOU HEARD THERE
IS AN INCREDIBLY BIZARRE
ALLEGATION FROM PERSON WHO,
ACCORDING TO OUR SOURCES, WAS
ACTUALLY PREPARED -- SHE WANTED
TO WORK FOR DONALD TRUMP OUTSIDE
THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN HE WASN'T
PRESIDENT AT MAR-A-LAGO, AND
ACCORDING TO PEOPLE THAT I
TALKED TO TONIGHT, OTHERS ADVISE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT NOT TO HIRE
HER.
IN OTHER WORDS, ACCORDING TO
"THE FEDERALIST" AND PEOPLE I
SPOKE TO AFTER JANUARY THE 6TH,
SHE WANTED TO WORK FOR
DONALD TRUMP, THAT BAD PERSON
SHE'S NOW TESTIFYING AGAINST.
AND NOW, GET THIS, CORDING TO
NBC -- BY THE WAY, ABC IS
REPORTING IT, FOX NEWS IS
REPORTING IT.
NBC'S PETER ALEXANDER, WE HAVE
CONFIRMED IT HERE AT FOX, "A
SOURCE CLOSE TO THE
SECRET SERVICE IS TELLING ME
BOTH BOBBY ENGEL, THE LEAD
AGENT, AND THE PRESIDENTIAL
LIMOUSINE DRIVER ARE BOTH
PREPARED TO TESTIFY UNDER OATH,
UNDER THE THREAT OF PERJURY,
THAT NEITHER MAN WAS EVER
ASSAULTED AND THAT MR. TRUMP,
THEN PRESIDENT, NEVER LONGED FOR
THE STEERING WHEEL."
A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHY HEARSAY
IS NOT ALLOWED IN A REAL COURT
OF LAW.
TODAY THE SO-CALLED WITNESS ALSO
CLAIMED PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTED
TO GET RID OF THE METAL
DETECTORS AT THE JANUARY 6 RALLY
AND ALLOW ARMED INDIVIDUALS TO
ATTEND.
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP FLAT OUT
DENIED THIS CLAIM AND POINTED
OUT A SIMPLE FACT.
ZERO GUNS WERE EVER DISCHARGED
BY THOSE THAT BREACHED THE
CAPITAL OR IN D.C. THAT DAY.
ACCORDING TO SO MANY SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS IN THE MEDIA MOB, IT
WAS HYPERVENTILATE AGAIN, WE GOT
HIM AGAIN, THIS TIME TRUMP,
RUSSIA, COLLUSION, WE GOT HIM,
LET'S IMPEACH HIM.
ANYWAY, THEY SAID THIS WAS A
GAME CHANGER.
WRONG AGAIN.
>> THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE
WRAPPED UP A STUNNING PUBLIC
HEARING, IT WAS, WE SHOULD MAKE
NO MISTAKE, ONE FOR THE HISTORY
BOOKS AND A COMPLETE
GAME CHANGER.
>> ONLY 25 OR 26 YEARS OLD,
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON EXPLODED THE
LIES AND THE MYTHS THAT THE
TRUMP TEAM HAVE BEEN
PERPETUATING FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR NOW.
>> THIS IS AN HISTORIC DAY, OUR
DEFENDANTS ARE GOING TO ASK US
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON.
THAT'S THE NAME THAT THEY WILL
KNOW.
THEY'RE GOING TO ASK US WHAT
THIS WAS LIKE TO WATCH THIS AND
TO LISTEN TO THIS BECAUSE THIS
IS A DAY THAT IS GOING TO LOOM
VERY LARGE IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> ONE LAST THING BIG PICTURE,
LIZ CHENEY BEGAN HER FINAL
COMMENTS BY SAYING THAT WE ARE
IN DEBT TO CASSIDY HUTCHINSON.
I THINK AMERICA AND DEMOCRACY IS
IN DEBT TO THIS YOUNG WOMAN.
>> Sean: REALLY?
JUST TAKE OUR WORD FOR IT.
SHE WASN'T EVEN THERE.
HEARSAY WITNESS, SOUND FAMILIAR?
OH, THAT WAS THE OTHER
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
AMID ALL THE ANTI-TRUMP GLEE,
THE MEDIA MOB AND THIS COMMITTEE
TO NEWS TO HIDE SEVERAL VERY
PERTINENT, IMPORTANT, PIVOTAL
FACTS INVOLVING ALL OF THIS.
FIRST, PRESIDENT TRUMP ALREADY
FACED A CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION AND IMPEACHMENT
OVER JANUARY 6TH.
HE WAS ACQUITTED.
SECOND, BIDEN'S
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR THE DOD
ALSO INVESTIGATED TERMS DOD AND
THEIR RESPONSE TO JANUARY 6TH,
AND GUESS WHAT?
THEY FOUND ZERO WRONGDOING.
AND THIRD, RIGHT HERE ON THIS
PROGRAM, WE HAVE CONFIRMED THAT
ON JANUARY THE 4TH, 2021, DURING
A MEETING AT THE OVAL OFFICE
FEATURING PRESIDENT TRUMP, CHIEF
OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS, ACTING
DEFENSE SECRETARY CHRIS MILLER,
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
CHIEF OF STAFF, CASH PATEL, WHO
WILL JOIN US TONIGHT, AND ALSO
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS, MARK MILLEY.
WELL, THE PRESIDENT AUTHORIZED,
AS IS REQUIRED BY LAW, UP TO
20,000 NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS BE
MADE AVAILABLE FOR SECURITY AT
THE CAPITAL AGAIN, AS THE LAW
REQUIRES.
THEN OF COURSE THAT BECOMES THE
JURISDICTION OF NANCY PELOSI AND
MURIEL BOWSER.
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS IN THAT
MEETING HAVE CONFIRMED ALL OF
THIS ON CAMERA, THAT THE
SECURITY REQUESTS IN FACT TOOK
PLACE.
INTERESTING FOR A GUY THAT WANTS
TO START OR INITIATE SOME TYPE
OF COUP, THAT HE WOULD BE
AUTHORIZING 20,000 TROOPS TO
PREVENT ANY TROUBLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CALLING UP THE GUARD AND THEN
IT BECAME -- THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND WENT TO NANCY PELOSI AND
TO THE MAYOR OF D.C., MURIEL
BOWSER.
DID YOU, AS REQUIRED BY LAW,
AUTHORIZE THAT?
>> 100% AND ATTESTED TO BY MANY
PEOPLE, AND THEY TURNED IT DOWN.
NANCY PELOSI TURNED IT DOWN.
>> MAYOR BOWSER'S WRITTEN
REFUSAL, THE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE LEADER OF THE
CAPITOL POLICE AND THEIR CHAIN
OF COMMAND SO THE DOD REFUSING
OUR REQUEST TO ALLOW
NATIONAL GUARD MEN AND WOMEN TO
STAGE JANUARY 4 AND 5 BEFORE
JANUARY 6TH.
>> DID YOU BOTH ASK FOR THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO BE CALLED UP?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT.
WE'VE MADE THAT VERY CLEAR, NOT
JUST ONCE, BUT ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE WAS PLENTY OF
NATIONAL GUARD ON THE READY IN
CASE THERE WAS SOME KIND OF
VIOLENCE.
>> I HAD A MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE
3RD OF JANUARY CONCERNING SOME
INTERNATIONAL THREATS AND AT THE
VERY END, HE ASKED IF THERE WERE
ANY REQUESTS FOR NATIONAL GUARD
SUPPORT.
>> WHAT WAS THE PRESIDENT'S
RESPONSE TO YOU WITH REGARD TO
THE REQUESTS MADE BY
MAYOR BOWSER?
>> FILLETED AND DO WHATEVER WAS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE
DEMONSTRATORS.
>> Sean: CHRIS MILLER ON THIS
PROGRAM CONFIRMS THAT.
TWO OF THE FOUR THAT WERE IN THE
ROOM ACTUALLY TESTIFIED BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE AND TOLD THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE THIS, SO WHY
WOULD PRESIDENT TRUMP MAKE THE
REQUEST IF HE WANTED THE CAPITAL
TO BE BREACHED THAT DAY, TWO
DAYS BEFOREHAND?
WHY WOULD D.C. MAYOR BOWSER, IN
WRITING, AND NANCY PELOSI,
REFUSED TO CALL UP THE GUARD?
IT'S HER DOMAIN, SHE'S IN CHARGE
OF CAPITAL SECURITY.
AND BY THE WAY, DONALD TRUMP
MADE THE TROOPS FULLY AVAILABLE.
HE FULLY AUTHORIZED AS REQUIRED
BY LAW, BY THE PRESIDENT, THEY
MADE THE CHOICE, IT WAS THEIR
JURISDICTION TO CALL THEM UP,
NOT DONALD TRUMP'S.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT FROM THE
SUMMER OF 2020.
WHY DID THE HOUSE THE HOUSE
SERGEANT-AT-ARMS AND THE SENATE
SERGEANT AT ARMS, WHY DID THEY
DENY THE CAPITOL POLICE CHIEFS
REQUEST FOR NATIONAL GUARD?
SIX SEPARATE TIMES.
AND BY THE WAY, WHY WANT ANYONE
ON THIS SO-CALLED JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE ASK ANY OF THESE
QUESTIONS?
WHY HAVE THEY NOT DEMANDED THE
EMAILS, THE TEXT, THE PHONE
RECORDS OF PELOSI, BOWSER, THE
SERGEANT OF ARMS IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE, THE
CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF AND
CHUCK SCHUMER, WHO GOT A LETTER
ON JANUARY 5TH SAYING THE INTEL
IS SAYING WE MIGHT HAVE
VIOLENCE?
THEY HAVEN'T BROUGHT ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE IN.
OF COURSE THIS IS NOT A REAL
COMMITTEE LOOKING FOR REAL
ANSWERS.
IF IT'S A POLITICAL THEATER
CONDUCTED EXCLUSIVELY ONLY BY
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY VOTED TO
IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON ON THIS
COMMITTEE -- YOU CAN'T MAKE IT
UP.
EVERYONE OF THEM HAVE VOTED TO
IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP.
BY THE WAY, SOME DIDN'T WANT TO
CERTIFY THE ELECTIONS OF EITHER
DONALD TRUMP OR GEORGE BUSH.
THIS IS WHY THEY WOULD NOT ALLOW
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN OR
CONGRESSMAN BANKS ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
THE DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA MOB,
THIS IS REALLY LITTLE MORE THAN,
WATCH, A FUN DISTRACTION FROM
THEIR BLEAK LYRICAL PROSPECTS?
LIZ CHENEY, WHAT, ONE FINAL
HURRAH AT THE BITTER END OF A
SAD AND SELF-SERVING POLITICAL
CAREER PARTNERING WITH THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT CALLED HER OWN
FATHER -- LET'S SEE -- A WAR
CRIMINAL, A MURDERER, A CROOK
WITH HALLIBURTON?
IF LAWMAKERS -- IF THEY REALLY
WANTED TO CONDUCT RIGHTEOUS
OVERSIGHT, PROTECT OUR COUNTRY,
THEY MIGHT WANT TO LOOK INTO THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT, WHO'S BEEN
SELLING ACCESS TO OUR GOVERNMENT
FOR YEARS.
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW IT FROM
WATCHING FAKE NEWS CNN OR MSDNC
OR ANY OF THE NETWORKS,
JOE BIDEN, YOU KNOW, HE WORKS
MOSTLY IN THE FAKE OVAL OFFICE
IT SEEMS, NOT TRUMP.
NEWLY UNCOVERED AUDIO REVEALS
THAT YOUR PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN,
KNEW ALL ABOUT HIS SON'S SKETCHY
FOREIGN BUSINESS VENTURES.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN CHINA, WE NOW
HAVE A 2018 VOICE MAIL YOU CAN
HEAR JOE'S VOICE, YOU KNOW IT'S
HIM.
HE MENTIONS A "NEW YORK TIMES"
ARTICLE ABOUT HUNTER'S DEAL WITH
THE SO-CALLED SPY CHIEF OF
CHINA, TELLS HIS SON THAT HE
THINKS HE'S IN THE CLEAR.
THINK OF McDERMOTT LISTEN TO
THIS.
>> IT'S 8:15.
ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT.
GIVE ME A CALL.
NOTHING URGENT.
JUST WANT TO TALK TO.
ABOUT THE ARTICLE IS GOING TO BE
PRINTED TOMORROW IS GOOD, CLEAR
AND ANYWAY, IF YOU GET A CHANCE,
GIVE ME A CALL, I LOVE YOU.
>> Sean: THAT WAS 2018.
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN 2020
AND HE WAS ASKED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND REPEATED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN THAT HE NEVER ONE TIME,
NOT ONCE, EVER SPOKE TO HUNTER
BIDEN ABOUT HIS FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALINGS AT ALL.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER, WE HAVE THE
TAPE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT, HOW MANY
TIMES HAVE YOU EVER SPOKEN TO
YOUR SON ABOUT HIS OVERSEAS
BUSINESS DEALINGS?
>> I'VE NEVER SPOKEN TO MY SON
ABOUT HIS OVERSEAS BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
I HAVE NEVER DISCUSSED WITH MY
SON OR MY BROTHER OR ANYONE ELSE
ANYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH THEIR
BUSINESSES, PERIOD.
AND WHAT I WILL DO IS THE SAME
THING WE DID IN OUR
ADMINISTRATION, AN ABSOLUTE WALL
BETWEEN PERSONAL AND PRIVATE IN
THE GOVERNMENT.
>> DO YOU STAND BY YOUR
STATEMENT THAT YOU DID NOT
DISCUSS ANY OF YOUR SON'S
OVERSEAS --
>> YES, I STAND BY THAT
STATEMENT.
>> Sean: WE EVEN HAVE PICTURES
OF JOE AND HUNTER AND ALL THOSE
FOREIGN BUSINESS PARTNERS.
JOEL MET THEM.
WHERE'S THAT INVESTIGATION?
JOE BIDEN WAS STRAIGHT UP LYING
TO OUR FACES.
HE DID IT OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND IT'S CLEAR FROM
HUNTER'S LAPTOP FROM HELL THAT
JOE PROFITED.
AND WHY, BY THE WAY, IS THIS WHY
JOE DOESN'T WANT TO LIFT TARIFFS
ON CHINA, BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
COMPROMISED?
HUNTER MADE A FORTUNE.
IS THIS WHAT JOE BIDEN APPROVED
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S PIPELINE WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY CANCELING THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE BECAUSE
HUNTER MADE A FORTUNE FROM A
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH?
THE MEDIA MOB, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THEY DON'T CARE ONE BIT.
IN FACT THEY DON'T CARE REALLY
ABOUT THE CORRUPTION, THE LION,
THE DISHONESTY, OR REAL
QUID PRO QUO'S, OR THE VIOLENCE
IN THE SUMMER OF 2020, BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T USE IT TO BASH THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
HAVE YOU EVER ASKED YOURSELF WHY
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A COMMITTEE
TO INVESTIGATE ALL OF THOSE
PEACEFUL RIOTS, 500 AND, WHAT,
74 OF THEM IN THE SUMMER OF
2020, THOUSANDS OF DEAD
AMERICANS, THOUSANDS OF INJURED
POLICE OFFICERS, BILLIONS IN
PROPERTY DAMAGE.
WHERE IS THAT COMMITTEE?
THE FEDERAL COURTHOUSE ATTACKED
EVERY SINGLE NIGHT FOR MONTHS IN
PORTLAND, A POLICE PRECINCT IN
MINNESOTA BURNED TO THE GROUND.
HISTORIC ST. JOHN'S CHURCH NEXT
TO THE WHITE HOUSE LIT A BLAZE?
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
ANY OF IT.
WHY, BECAUSE IT DOESN'T HELP
THEM POLITICALLY?
THEY CAN'T USE IT TO BASH
DONALD TRUMP ONE MORE TIME FOR
GOOD OLD FUN?
THE MEDIA, D.C. POLITICIANS WERE
EITHER SILENT ABOUT THOSE RIOTS,
OR DIDN'T WANT TO ANGER THEIR
LEFT-WING RADICAL BASE.
SO THEY EITHER WERE SILENT OR
THEY LIED TO US AND SAID THEY
WERE MOSTLY PEACEFUL, AND WE
KNOW THEY WEREN'T, OR THEY'RE
JUST OUTRIGHT ENCOURAGED IT LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS DID BY PROMOTING
THAT BAIL FUND RIOTERS TO GET
THEM OUT OF JAIL AND TELLING THE
MOB THAT, LISTEN, THEY SHOULDN'T
STOP, THEY ARE TO STOP, THEY
WON'T STOP, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
STOP, AND YOU NEED TO TAKE NOTE,
YOU NEED TO BE AWARE.
WHERE THOSE HEARINGS INTO 574
RIOTS IN 2020?
AND WHILE WE'RE AT IT, WHERE THE
HEARINGS ABOUT QUID PRO QUO'S,
ESPECIALLY THE ONE WITH JOE?
YOU'RE NOT GETTING A BILLION
DOLLARS IN LESS YOU FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR THAT IS INVESTIGATING
MY SON IS MAKING MILLIONS
WITHOUT ANY EXPERIENCE AT ALL.
CURRENTLY DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA
MOB ARE SO OUTRAGED OVER
DONALD TRUMP'S QUID PRO QUO THAT
DIDN'T EXIST, BUT THEY IGNORED
THE REAL QUID PRO QUO.
MIGHT RECALL.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE MILLION DOLLARS.
THEY SAID YOU'RE NOT AUTHORITY,
YOU ARE NOT THE PRESIDENT.
AND I SAID CALL HIM.
I SAID I'M TELLING YOU, YOU'RE
NOT GETTING A BILLION DOLLARS.
SAID YOU'RE NOT GETTING A BILL
IN IT, I'M GOING TO BE LEAVING
HER IN A THINK IT WAS SIX HOURS
AND I SAID I'M LEAVING IN SIX
HOURS, IF THE PROSECUTOR IS NOT
FIRED, YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE
MONEY.
WHILE SON OF A [BLEEP].
HE GOT FIRED BURIED
>> Sean: THEY FIRED HIM.
ALL I ASK FOR -- ALL HE DID WAS
OFFER TO WITHHOLD A BILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT'S IT QUID PRO QUO BY JOE.
REMEMBER THE MEDIA MOB,
DEMOCRATS, ACCUSED TRUMP OF
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THEY LIVE FOR THREE LONG YEARS.
TURNS OUT THE ONLY REAL RUSSIA
COLLUSION WAS HILLARY RODHAM
CLINTON'S DIRTY MISINFORMATION
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
THE MEDIA MOB AND THE DEMOCRATS
THEN LIED ON THE EVE OF THE 2020
ELECTION AND THEY CLAIMED
WITHOUT ONE SHRED OF EVIDENCE --
OH, NO, THIS HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP, IT'S ALL RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION, A COMPLETE AND
TOTAL LIE.
EVERYTHING THEY ACCUSED TRUMP OF
THEY ARE GUILTY OF.
DEMAGOGUERY RULES THE DAY INSIDE
THIS MODERN, REALLY STRANGE,
REALLY RADICAL DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY.
BUT NOW WITH MASSIVE POLICY
FAILURES AT HOME AND ABROAD,